Let's say that fulfilling revenge was
Masamune-sama's purpose in life and his earnest desire, but the
shock of suddenly losing it cannot be made up for by dating Aki-sama.
[Music] It's
not like I really like him.
Did I like you back then? Is
the past really that important?
This is a late topic, but I
met Masamune-sama a long time ago.
[Music] I
remember long before Aki-sama.  It was the
wedding of Yuriko, a relative of mine. Masamune's
family was invited because of the groom's company.
[Music] I'm sorry, but even if you say that, it's understandable that you
don't remember it.
[Music]
I also forgot about half of it until I got into surgery.
Masamune-sama, I remember you saying earlier that you didn't like it that much.
[Applause]
[Music] I
remember it. It's
frustrating.  But I
couldn't refute it. It's true that I tried to start a love game based on my own
poor memories. Mr. Kiyomiya,
but Mr. Masamune, even if the beginning was impure, I had
no intention of degrading myself after that.  I'm sorry, but
I
can say without hesitation that
the past doesn't matter. I
fell in love with you right here and now.
[Music]